i don't know how the hell you know how
to make this star trek with the effects
and the things i mean you've got to be a
genius to make that i think you're a
genius
i can't even imagine explaining what you
want yeah right it i can't even and then
i want it to look like space and then
the world and that's teachers do you
draw or do you yeah
let's say i have a scene where some guy
you know it's some crazy [ __ ]
shootout
how do you explain to these dudes how to
get this on the screen so a lot of it is
uh sitting down with uh either
storyboard artists or previous people
that make little sort of it's almost
like a cartoon that you make before and
we have an amazing visual effects
supervisor named roger guyette who is
brilliant from ilm uh we just we work
with amazing people so if there's a big
chase there was there was a fight in the
movie that was going to be just
on the street right and then we then the
the first a.d
uh tommy gormley said assistant director
yes the director said you know it would
be great if they were like on a vehicle
moving and all of a sudden it became the
biggest craziest [ __ ] thing ever
where there's this fight on this like
garbage barge barreling through a
futuristic san francisco wow
huge ridiculous sequence
and
one of the fun things is you figure out
what do you want the shot to be how do
you want it to look yeah because a lot
of times you can get into crazy cg stuff
but then it like looks fake right so if
you think well how does how do i make it
look real so first of all like it does
look real well we that because we shot
outside yeah so how do you figure how to
make it look real well there are a lot
of uh i know this sounds obvious but
a lot of times scenes that take place
exterior scenes for some reason are shot
on a stage right and your eye goes
that's not sunlight so we shot outdoors
we built a big piece of this thing we
actually were able to do big wire cams
some helicopter shots we had real smoke
the thing was actually moving so even
before we put in anything to replace you
know the green screen it already looks
and feels like you're legitimately in a
real place
it's it's just wait a second what you
just described
how long is that on scene that uh on
screen that whole scene it's about um
you know 90 seconds all right 90 seconds
that sounds tremendously expensive to
pull up amazing amounts yeah it's got to
be a tremendous fortune just to shoot
that 90 seconds even though you know the
movie had a healthy budget it was like
180 million dollars it's insane
the movie is so huge right that figuring
out how to get everything you think 180
million can afford anything we want
right all of a sudden you're like it's
like buying an apartment buying a house
you have to make choices yeah you think
you think oh i'm rich i i got everything
i got everything i need right like the
richest guy in the world is like and i
swear to god that guy's like wait the
house costs how much so in other words
when somebody says hey now let's take it
outside let's make it on a helicopter
let's do this that
all of a sudden you go well wait a
second that's going to cost me 20
million so what we did is we we filmed
everything
with almost uh like 10 exception in this
one
place in la so we shot all this stuff we
had all these sets right next to each
other some outdoors some indoors uh on
this in this place in playa del rey in
l.a so we had like a volcano set right
next to this garbage bar set right next
to this jungle set right next to this
you know big hanger it just it saved a
ton of money because we weren't moving